[Musique]
mais bon pro 15 pouces gris sidéral 7959
euros là
si vous suivez mes vidéos il vous aura
pas échappé que je suis client chez
apple
j'ai un macbook pro sans lequel je
travaille c'est un vieux macbook pro
macbook pro 2011 et je me suis posé la
question depuis quelques temps de
changer d'évoluer est passé vers un
produit plus performant je fais
aujourd'hui uniquement en full hd parce
que mon mac de 2011 paraît pas de filmer
en cas de cas de montants quelques as
sahab
c'est un truc de dingue donc quand j'ai
appris la nouvelle tôt un nouveau
macbook pro et est sorti je me suis posé
la question
une fois de plus bonnes questions chaque
année je me suis dit est ce que c'est
cette année que je les bascules et j ai
regardé la fiche technique
j'ai regardé ce qui est annoncé du côté
du 15 pouces surtout pour le montage
parce que déjà que l'écran est pas hyper
confortable en travaillant sur 10 15
pouces pour faire du montage
selon lui 13 pouces chez fidal me
flinguer les yeux je me suis donc posé
la question j'ai regardé et j'ai regardé
à peu près la configuration qui pourrait
m'intéresser gelé directement sur le
plus haut de gamme sur ce qu'il va y
avoir le plus en termes de puissance
pour filer en 4k pavant de latence des
exports rapide et que ça soit bien
cohérent et bien fait et j'ai vu le prix
7959 euros c'est hallucinant c'est
extrêmement cher après après je crache
pas dans la soupe
j'aime beaucoup les produits apple
j'aime leur environnement prouve que les
machines sont vraiment bien on est sur
une toute nouvelle machine nouvelle
génération nouveaux processeurs intel si
quelque chose qui marche
il n'y a aucun souci mais c'est qu'en
termes de politique tarifaire c'est très
cher ah non on peut effectivement dire
c'est un produit destiné aux
professionnels
est-ce que tu as besoin en faisant de la
vidéo 4k d'un tel produit pas forcément
la question ça tourne un peu dans
l'autre sens dont d'ailleurs d'ici
quelques jours je vous invite à me
suivre à vous abonner parce que dans
quelques jours je vous faire une vidéo
qu'un peu la continuité de ce que j'ai
fait une dernière les faits une vidéo
qu'elle macbook achetés en 2010 est là
maintenant que ce premier sorti je vous
faire une vidéo qu'elle macbook acheté
en 2018 je serais surpris qu'apple nous
sortent en septembre un nouveau macbook
macbook air peut-être on va quand même
se poser cette question
quitte à refaire une vidéo après s'il ya
des nouveautés qui dit apple dit en tout
cas dans la gamme macbook pro puissance
ordinateur permettra de travailler pour
un usage professionnel
et là il ya de nouveaux produits qui
sont arrivés le macbook pro 15 pouces et
un macbook pro 13 pouces sur le macbook
pro 15 pouces vous avez un processeur
intel core i7 ou inneov hexa coeurs
cadencé à 2,1
giga hertz électoraux boost vous pouvez
monter jusqu'à 4,8
giguère il annoncé comme étant 70% plus
puissant que la génération précédente
vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 32 gigas de
ram ddr 4 le processeur graphique c'est
un rabais en pro avec 4 gigas de mémoire
vidéo dédiée dans toutes les
configurations
vous pouvez stocker jusqu'à 4 gigas en
ssd pour l'affichage vous avez du trou
tonnes la puce t2 d'apple pour la
sécurisation in touch bar un nouveau
clavier plus silencieux le touch heidi
pour le macbook pro 13 pouces vous avez
un processeur intel core i5 ou i7
quadricoeur cadencé jusqu'à 2,7 giga
hertz avec le turbo boost jusqu'à quel
point 5 giga hertz le processeur
graphique est intégrée c'est une telle
l'iris plus 655 avec son actu mégaoctets
de mémoire
ed rennes vous pouvez monter jusqu'à
deux terrains de stockage en ssd
vous avez aussi l'affichage trou tonnes
la puce t2 d'apple le touch bas elton
chaibi donc des machines qui sont
relativement différentes ont pas
forcément avoir le même usage sur l'eau
comme sur l'autre vous avez un
processeur intel de huitième génération
quelque chose de beaucoup plus rapide
permettra d'aller plus loin dans les
calculs
vous avez un clavier de troisième
génération qu'il ya un petit peu changé
par rapport à ce qu elle avant il ya eu
pas mal de problèmes sur le clavier
papillon là vous avez un clavier qui a
annoncé comme étant plus silencieux des
connecteur thunderbolt roi vous pouvez
connecter jusqu'à deux moniteurs 5k
externe
la luminosité c'est du 510 et vous avez
la gamme de couleurs p3 donc deux
machines vraiment complète vous pouvez
complètement personnalisé en fonction de
vos besoins
la puce de d'apple vous nous en parler
rapidement elle va venir renforcer la
sécurité
démarrage sécurisé chiffrement des
données et elle apporte 10 séries pour
la première fois sur un mac ça c'est
cool
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'apple continue en
renouveler sa gamme de macbook pro qui
s'adresse vraiment aux professionnels
les macbook pro sont des machines
vraiment bien très puissante forcément
là c'est cher ce sont des produits à
usage professionnel
si vous avez sur le modèle 13 pouces
vous pouvez choisir 128 go de stockage
256 et rajouter touch et touch heidi en
256 un voyage forcément tout de suite le
prix augmente vous êtes quasiment à 2000
euros
et si vous en voulez toujours plus vous
pouvez prendre 512
de stockage on est à 2249 euros c'est
énorme
vous êtes toujours les options là vous
êtes sur le processeur intel core i5 si
vous allez sur le i7 l'addition continue
à grimper
si vous voulez 16 giga de ram ça grimpe
encore si vous voulez un ssd toujours
plus grands carrément passé sur un
terrain plus 500 euros 2 tera plus 1500
euros les tarifs s'envolent les
logiciels préinstallés vont pas
forcément besoins évoluent tout de suite
on est à 4000 349 euros si vous voulez
un 13 pouces gonflé à bloc
si tout de suite quelque chose de cher
extrêmement cher si vous voulez de la
puissance à ordinateur équivalent mac
est quand même très très cher sans le 15
pouces vous avez plusieurs possibilités
vous pouvez prendre processeur cadencé à
2,2 ghz 256 giga de stockage là par
contre vous avez touch heidi est
atteinte du bar qui sont directement et
plus oui vous avez un tarif de base 2799
auront vous montez au dessus en 512 3299
euros cadencé à 2,6 gigahertz et 512
giga de stockage et là ne s'arrêtent pas
les prix s'envolent là vous êtes sur le
17 si vous voyez sur le i 9 plus 340
euros au lieu d'avoir 16 giga de mémoire
ddr4 vous passer carrément à 32 giga
plus 480 euros
le stockage les prix s'envolent
complètement jusqu'à capter à 3840 euros
là on n'a pas forcément besoin tout de
suite de quatre terrains de stockage
fait c'est super cher et voyez vous êtes
sur le tarif 7959 euros c'est très cher
les macbook pro sont puissants
surpuissant ils sont chers très très
cher mais ça apple vous le savez c'est
pas nouveau
si vous voulez un macbook pro si vous
voulez des produits apple ça se paye
vous avez qu à voir avec l'iphone 10
l'année dernière il a passé les 1000
euros le positionnement stratégique
d'apple reste toujours dans le haut de
gamme et là sur des produits comme ça on
voit très bien que c'est destiné à des
produits professionnels limite luxe
apple a effectivement annoncé la couleur
avec le macbook pro le plus puissant
vous pouvez monter de la vidéo cinq cas
directement dans votre machine sans
aucun problème bien évidemment n'aura
pas de latence si vous achetez une
machine comme ça vous allez le temps de
voir venir c'est un produit vous allez
garder dix ans sans aucun problème ok
par contre il faut pouvoir se le
permettre je suis pas persuadé qu'en
produits surboosté comme ça corresponde
à tout le monde en termes de prix en
termes de budget 7 vient carrément
énorme
moi quand je veux renouveler mardi
heures la question va se poser une fois
de plus du macbook pro déjà parce que je
suis habitué à l'environnement apple
macos
je connais parfaitement bien mon
logiciel de montage c'est final cut pro
donc quand on est habitué à un logiciel
pas s'embêter à le rechercher un autre
jeu cette première est un excellent
logiciel
je trouve les ordinateurs très puissants
et moins cher souligne de ce 10 mai
quand on est habitué
c'est toujours compliqué de changer
malgré tout la question se pose la can
des tarifs vraiment énorme
le lien quand je l'aï acheté ils
écoutent à peu près 1800 euros
c'était déjà une machine qui sample 7 en
2011 il ya quelques années les tarifs
ont augmenté depuis c'est pas une
nouveauté mais malgré tout les tarifs
sont quand même très très très élevé au
jour d'aujourd'hui
si je veux acheter un macbook pro la
question à se poser c'est quel vêtement
utilisation dans 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans parce
qu'il ya la question aujourd'hui au jour
j pour l'instant je filme en 1080p
j'ai besoin d'un peu plus de puissance
pour pouvoir travailler en cas de cas
d'une manière complètement fluide avec
mon disque dur 256 giga je suis quand
même relativement limitée puis je m'en
vais tout le temps il faut que j'arrive
à intéresser je peux voir de terrain ça
serait bien quatre terrasses est
extrêmement cher donc ne parlons même
pas genesis de stockage à l'extérieur ça
c'est pas le problème mais tout de suite
tout ça c'est très chiant dès lors vous
voulez quelque chose qui va durer dans
le temps qui n'a pas être obsolètes
d'ici cinq ans vous devez vous poser la
question aujourd'hui d'acheter le
processeur qui va pouvoir vieillir
correctement d'abord assez d espace de
stockage d'avoir suffisamment de ram
pour encaisser de la capca et que
sais-je encore des 6 4 5 ans peut-être
en 8k on sait pas on verra donc ça veut
dire une machine puissante donc est ce
que ces macbook pro 13 pouces et 15
pouces sont intéressants très clairement
oui
la fiche technique et la soie papier ils
ont l'air d'être vraiment intéressant je
dirais presque à voir lors de phases de
test mais on connaît les produits apple
on connaît la finition les produits
j'imagine sont faits au cordeau sont
vraiment extrêmement top et doit
vraiment tourner à fond la caisse
là dessus je me fais absolument aucun
souci maintenant la question c'est happy
s'adressent ces produits tout de suite
je pense aux professionnels le
particulier c'est extrêmement cher vous
n'êtes pas forcément avec des sommes
folles pour acheter un macbook pro et
quand je dis sommes folles c'est des
ordinateurs a plu
2500 euros si vous faites du montage
vidéo n'allez pas sur un 13 pouces
oui on fait des petits montages de temps
en temps ça passe mais si comme moi fait
des montages tous les jours une à deux
fois par jour vous êtes tout en dessus
en train de travailler
le minimum c'est 15 pouces si vous
voulez pas vous fatiguer les yeux après
je vous conseille d'abord un moniteur
extérieur un ou deux moniteurs pour être
vraiment tranquille et travaille de
façon organisée mais c'est pareil
une fois de plus ça c'est un coup dès
lors vous voulez des écrans qui sont
complètement compatible est extrêmement
optimisés pour des machines comme celle
là ça veut dire que aujourd'hui en tant
que professionnel ou en tant qu'amateur
plus plus plus qui peut se le permettre
acheter apple s'est acheté du luxe
néanmoins je ne peux vous les recommande
et parce que les produits apple sont
toujours d'une bonne qualité
il est absolument rien à dire dessus
tout est optimisé
c'est vraiment top à la question est-ce
qu'il faut acheter ces ordis là si vous
en avez vraiment le besoin et vous avez
la capacité d'investissement oui mais
attention c'est pas fait pour tout le
monde tout le monde ne trouvera pas son
compte
c'est pas la peine d'acheter un
ordinateur qui ont finalement utilisé
qu'à 30 40 50% donc réfléchissez bien
avant de l'acheter
ce que je vous conseille de rester
connecté parce que je vous le dise ces
quelques jours je vous faire une vidéo
qu'elle macbook acheté en 2018 on va les
comparer on va regarder un petit peu
l'offre globale voir ce qui est
intéressant à d'autres produits que le
macbook pro il ya d'autres produits que
celui ci ait aussi des produits
reconditionnés
on va se poser la question par rapport
aux utilisations et par rapport à vos
besoins réels donc restez connectés en
attendant vous dites moi ce que vous
pensez de ces macbook pro 2018 est ce
que vous les trouvez cool
est ce que vous regrettez qu'apple ne
vais pas garder sous le coude pour la
présentation du mois de septembre
est ce que vous trouvez ça bien qu'ils
les sortent comme ça tout de suite
au mois de juillet avant le 14 juillet
après le 4 juillet pour les américains
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous
marquez tout sans commentaire
comment vous les trouvez et puis au
final au final est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par un ses macbook
pro est est ce que vous seriez prêt à
mettre plus de 7900 euros
mark et moi tout ça d'ici là je vous
invite à les céder je les pousse à vous
abonner et on se retrouve très très très
bientôt parce qu'un plein de choses à
dire sur ses macbook pro est sûre pas
notre produit à très bientôt son visage
nous embrasse ton
[Musique]